[Musique]
vendi
40000 je trava pas mais j'ai tombéin
comment j'allais
payer les factur tout ça des choses
comme
ça
[Musique]
souvent elle refusé de fait la
césarienne et c'est pour cela qu' elle
ne venait même pas à l'hôpital elle
partait dans des petits centres là à la
cité et elle ne venait pas parce que SAV
que si elle vient d'ici le cû est
exorbitant n'était pas capable de
pouvoir payer ça la mortalité maternelle
a diminué ça diminué sensiblement parce
que nous recevons m de grossesse extra
rompu où la malade est tr de saigner bon
si on était dans dans l'ancien système
où il fallait payer pour qu'on puisse
intervenir ça être difficile c'est pour
cela qu' beaucoup de femmes mourraent
d'abord elle mourit par des
hémorragies le président de la
République c'est un fervant défenseur
hein des des droits de la femme et je
pense que les femmes se sentent en
confiance par rapport à cette position
du président de la République ils se
disent nous avons un président qui nous
comprend nous avons un président qui
comprend nos problèmes à la présidence
c'est la première fois qu'on voit des
femmes occuper des places euh des places
décisions on va dire il y en a jamais eu
depuis depuis l'indépendance on a une
directrice de de cabinet adjointe on a
une première porte-parole que je suis ça
n'avait jamais existé par le
passé
[Musique]
il y a peut-être de plus en plus
d'affiches avec les les les figures
féminines mais sur terrain vous verrez
ces femmes se plaindre de ne pas pouvoir
bien faire la campagne électorale soit
pas parce qu'elles n'ont pas
suffisamment de moyens soit parce
qu'elles ne sont pas suffisamment
accompagnés et la le résultat final
c'est que il y en a pas assez qui sont
élus des habits acheter des
habits ie comment
réduire nous avons par exemple la
Constitution qui prône la parité mais le
problème c'est plus dans les les les
lois la mise en application de cela sur
terrain c'est vrai qu'on a aussi une loi
sur la parité mais jusque-là sur terrain
on narrive pas encore à atteindre ce
niveau c'est là on se dit qu'il faut
vraiment un grand travail qui continue à
être fait nous organisations de la
société civile devrions continuer euh
euh pas seulement agir mais également
mener des actions de plédoyer pour qu'au
niveau de l'État les questions des
femmes soi de plus en plus
priorisé j'aiis ici on parle de la femme
on don la parole à la sont devenus des
idoles de nous le jeunes directement les
téléphone pour voir ce que ce que les
influenceurs
ont je veux que d'autres femmes
m'écoutent qu'il est temps pour elle de
ne pas se cacher de ne pas rester à la
maison on doit laisser la la la jeune
femme s'édiquer s'instruire selle ve
faire l'université faut la laisser faut
pas bloquer que les parents ne bloquent
pas les jeunes filles just non reste là
tu finis tu as en diplôme d'état va au
mariage non non non que les parents
laissent les femmes aller de l'avant les
jeunes femmes aller de l'avant
s'instruire d'avantage pour un jour
impacter la la
société